what is your background who are you well
I'm somewhat of Serial entrepreneur had
a few lots of failures and a few
successes and the founder uh co-founder
of bridge Investment Group 48 billion
dollars assets under management so it
grew pretty well give all the credit to
the team people call me all the time
they say Paul I have a question about
real estate I said I don't know I don't
know anything about real estate they're
like you're the founder of a
multi-billion dollar real estate fund I
said no I know how to build teams and I
know how to have the vision from the
beginning to create it fast forward got
recruited about 10 years ago to uh help
on an undercover Rescue Mission the one
that is featured in The Sound of Freedom
movie my character is played by Eduardo
voroski I'm Pablo I'm the fund manager
who gets recruited to help fund the
operation and play a role and we can go
deep into that since that time I have
led or played a key part in over 70
undercover rescue missions in 15
countries retired from my job focused
full-time on philanthropy zero social
media for 10 years came out
just four months ago to share the
stories and inspire people
talk to me about how a fund manager ends
up becoming an operative for a
anti-child sex trafficking ring sting
well I I have I have a special set of
skills from previous life that makes me
somewhat safe in a dangerous place but
what had happened is our attorney
general called me about 10 years ago and
he I I'm like What's Up Ag and he's like
what's up Hutch and and uh he said hey I
gotta talk to you about something it's
pretty dark he said I know you're really
involved with child-related Charities I
was on the Make-A-Wish Board of
Directors for 10 years a bunch of things
and he said he said this is the fastest
growing criminal Enterprise in the world
and good people don't know that it's
happening I'm like well what is it he
says it's it's human trafficking and
this situation is child trafficking and
I'm like what like children being sold
for for what I mean how does that work
and he says for sex and I'm like no that
doesn't happen he said now he says
there's this Homeland Security agent
he's in Colombia he's identified some
children down there I want to introduce
you to him and and fast forward I end up
helping to raise of money and fund the
what he thought was going to be 20
children that were in Cartagena but then
he called me and he said Paul he said
I'm here in Cartagena there's not just
20 children there's more than 50 there's
more than 100 and what I didn't know is
that that he had already had some
conversations with with Sean Reyes the
attorney general and and were
specifically looking for somebody who
could play a role like a Jeffrey Epstein
somebody who was was well off that that
had this Playboy background so to speak
that that also could handle himself in a
dangerous place and so he called me and
he said Paul he says there's more than a
hundred children that are tied to these
different rings I think we can Rescue
all of them on the same day at the same
time but I need your help in a big way
and I'm like well how much do you need
and he said I need you can you be in
Colombia in two days
and I was sitting there I was in in
Atlanta Georgia I was at a conference I
was raising money from billionaire
families for the fund and I hung up the
phone of my business partners like did
you really just commit to that
I'm like yeah if I can if there's
something about me that they can use to
help rescue these kids and now or later
the co-founder my friend John calls me
up he's like Paul uh don called me told
me what you're doing have you thought
through this he says this is this is
really dangerous he said you're you're
set you could you could sell out today
buy an island be happy the rest of your
life I'm like would I really be happy
John if I bought an island if I bought a
yacht or whatever I said I said tell me
this if if
if I was doing something else dangerous
tomorrow if I was climbing Everest you
and I have the same conversation goes
yeah we probably would I said and when
I'm 95 years old and I look back upon my
life and I say I climb this mountain and
I built this multi-billion dollar
company and I helped rescue this many
children from slavery from being
trafficked which of them matters at all
he's like yeah you're right you got to
do this
just how big of a just how big of a
problem is child trafficking because I I
thought this was some Middle Ages I
didn't think that this was the sort of
thing that happened and certainly not in
you know relatively developed countries
yeah yeah it's human trafficking as a
whole it's the fastest growing criminal
Enterprise in the world and the second
most profitable surpass the illegal arms
trade and many think it's going to
surpass the drug trade within the next
couple years
and and you know quote out of the movie
is that we had Jim Caviezel say because
you can sell a bag of coke once you can
sell a child a 5 10 year old child you
can sell them five ten fifteen times a
day for the next five or ten years and
it's a big problem now I will say this
what's depicted in the sound of Freedom
movie those things happen those children
those stories that we pulled from all
these rescue missions we compiled a
bunch of those stories together to
create the narrative for the movie
itself so yes children are taken just
like that there's there there's all
kinds of different ways that these kids
are brought in but the majority of child
trafficking is right under our noses
over 70 percent of children that are
being sold for sex
sleep in their own beds at night
and and people are surprised at that
they're like oh that's not traffic no
they're being sold by their Uncle
they're being sold by their their cousin
or their their babysitter even by their
parents and it happens a lot where the
parents were involved and so and and as
we're as we're trying to really fix this
problem yes sending in some Navy Seals
and going undercover and finding these
kids and pulling them out yeah that's
all big and Rambo and everybody gets
behind it yay let's go fix this problem
but the reality is every one of us needs
to look in our own backyard in our own
basement and our own homes and say what
kind of things are are potentially
dangerous for my own children in the
relationships that that they have and
the people that they go over to Etc
literally one in every four women on the
planet
has been a victim of sexual violence as
a child and most of them in their own
homes the number of men is smaller but
is still a serious problem yeah I've
seen Tim Kennedy has shared videos like
this where it's um you know some uh car
circles the outside of a playground
where it's a Saturday morning and the
kids are playing tennis or something and
someone comes over and says oh I'm here
to pick you up and mum's not here or
whatever like that uh almost like taken
Liam Neeson's daughter's style
um cartel stuff is the more
uh outrageous the more kind of attention
grabbing but as you've suggested there a
lot of the time the problem is actually
a lot closer to home it really is and
and as as people leave the movie studio
mad as hell saying okay I want to do
something I want to do something what do
I do the worst thing they can do is try
to go be a Rambo and go into some other
country and find these kids you know
you're going to get killed you're going
to get arrested that doesn't work right
the best thing you can do is actually go
home and hug your kids people are like
what how's that going to fix it no the
the the children that are being brought
into this are from Foster programs
broken families runaways those are the
ones that are being actually traffic
trafficked like that that the kids that
are that are being abused and traffic
from their own homes these are these are
ones who have super low self-esteem they
don't have a relationship with you as
their father such that where they can
come in and say hey Dad you know what
I'm I'm really uncomfortable when when I
have to hug Uncle Harry or or when I go
over to so-and-so's house whatever those
are things that we need to have that
relationship with our kids keep them
safe absolutely
who are the biggest consumers of
human trafficking child trafficking and
sort of trafficking related material
Americans
America both Americans yeah North
American the United States is the number
one producer and consumer of child
pornography and the number one consumer
of pedophilia especially traveling
abroad so one of the reasons why I was
recruited was that that a lot of these
traffickers were used to wealthy
well-spoken financially secure connected
businessman who had big ass egos that
guys like Jeffrey Epstein that decide
they want to go and have this big sex
party in this foreign country and so so
it wasn't an odd thing
for me to come down saying yeah I'll
fund your your sex Hotel I'll put eight
million bucks what does it say but what
does it say that they looked at you and
said yeah that guy that guy reminds me
of a pedophile she's like what okay this
is funniest right here are you
ready for this story so so Sean Reyes I
wasn't there for this meeting but I was
told that that uh the homeland security
agent that the that Jim Caviezel plays
in the movie he was trying to find
somebody could play this role and he was
in a meeting and he had he had uh Josh
Romney Mitt Romney's son was there and
Sean Reyes the Attorney General a couple
of others and he says you know this is
what I need I need somebody who's who
can play this role that that you know
would be safe in this dangerous place
and whatever and Sean says well have you
ever met Paul Hutchinson and Josh Josh
Romney said well Paul would be perfect
and later I told him I said I don't
think that's a compliment guys
yeah so okay um you mentioned about the
America thing which is terrifying and
mind-blowing how interconnected and
Global is this are we are people
children from Southern Africa
sub-Saharan Africa are they being flown
over the children and and human
traffickers tend to stay within a
particular sort of geographic net here's
what we found is in most of these rescue
operations they're about half or more of
the children were from that country more
brought in from Super poor areas the the
parents were duped whatever they were
brought in half of them though that were
were brought from other places in fact
that that first rescue that was depicted
in in the sound of freedom
I was sitting there on this chair and
these traffickers brought out these four
virgins scared to death one of them was
an 11 year old boy brought in from Haiti
they gave him cocaine that morning
because he was so scared I mean what
kind of effed up monster thinks that
that's attractive right it is is
sickening to me but these children there
were there were children from Asia there
were children from from Dominican
Republic children from Haiti children
from all over there in fact the last one
that I did before I came out from being
undercover I was in Ecuador and most of
the kids that they brought were were
trafficked in from Venezuela because
there was a there was a lot of upheaval
in the country and there's there's
poverty that's there and and it's super
easy for these traffickers to go in and
bring these kids into other countries
promising them a job and of course their
job is being trafficked yeah when
everyone's starving and will do anything
for food the vigilance that you're going
to have against your child being
trafficked is going to go through the
floor when you're trying to keep food on
the table okay so you get this phone
call your business partners think that
you're a crazy person uh you decide that
you're going to go to Colombia two days
hence
actually first off you mentioned that
you had a background that predisposed
you to be able to be in kinetic or high
pressure situation so what's that
background yeah a couple things we've
found that our best undercover operators
are not we had special forces guys with
a lot of them which is great but the
best ones were ones that were highly
trained in in hand-to-hand combat are
you familiar with Krav Maga I am yeah so
for your listeners who don't know that
you know that other other martial arts
karate and whatnot battle your Sensei
three points when you kick them in the
leg Krav is Brick to their head and go
home to your family right it's Israeli
Special Forces hand-to-hand combat and
it's it's the most lethal on Earth every
move they don't breathe they don't see
they don't walk I can take away a gun
faster than they can pull a trigger
every single time and and it's that kind
of of training that you have to have
when you're in that situation you don't
have guns and night vision goggles and
and a spotter you just don't you know
you're face to face with guys selling
you eight-year-old children that would
kill you in a heartbeat if they knew who
you really were and so being able to be
super in and and a lot of it we never
had I I served on 70 undercover rescue
missions not once did I have to use they
say did anything ever get kinetic oh
things things got super dangerous super
dangerous a couple times but not to the
point now we had four traffickers that
actually ended up dying on missions but
they were they were killed by each other
by other traffickers and which yes
exactly like that's all right we'll take
care of that so but there were some
super dangerous situations but never to
the point where we had to be involved I
was I was sitting talking I was standing
on a sidewalk talking to one trafficker
in Latin America we called him Diablo he
had devil horns that were tattooed on
his forehead and there was another
trafficker we had connected with earlier
we called him the Candyman he had a
candy shop and he was selling he was
making his big money selling kids but
that's how he's connecting with people
and customers well well Candyman saw me
talking with with Diablo and I've got
video of this he he he walks right up to
him and I kind of step away and boom the
clocks him throws him out in the middle
of the street they're beating the
out of each other right there in front
of us over this Turf War because
Candyman was like no these guys are
gonna they're they're gonna when we go
into a city we want to make sure we
connect with every single trafficker
that's there so we don't just take out
one or two and the others fill in so
we're in there long enough and they
always start fighting with each other
okay so you've got this background in
hand-to-hand combat that means that
you're going to be able to at least
control yourself parasympathetically
when the confrontation perhaps happens
but
like
it doesn't matter how many decades of
Israeli Special Forces fighting practice
you've done you're not trained like
you're not trained for this I'm sure
that you've had some coaching to deal
with mergers and Acquisitions and
hostile takeovers and stuff for your
business which is also you know I got
some communication and I've spent time
in boardrooms and blah blah blah but
none of these things are anything close
to uh Special Forces uh information
Technologies surveillance
counter-terrorism none of this and
they've given me 48 hours and during
that time you need to get yourself over
there so talk us through the story
you're you're on the plane you're
heading down there you arrive what
happens next
actually I was supposed to fly right
into Cartagena well I there was a
layover in Bogota and during The Layover
I was supposed to get incarnate of that
night and the the meeting with the
traffickers was the next morning well I
get into Bogota and something happened
they canceled the flight going into
Cartagena and and everybody was pissed
like we're in the airport now realize
this I had come from a wealth conference
right I had I had thousand dollar
cufflinks on my on my cuffs right I was
a Target and at the time at the time
Bogota Colombia it was 25 is what you
needed to pay somebody to knock somebody
off right so so if if I looked like I
was worth any more than 25 dollars I was
a Target so I'm in a I'm in a custom
suit I've got I've got a custom
cufflinks I've got a my Gucci bag I was
going down there on purpose dressed as
this wealthy guy that was going to pay
for this thing right and they cancel the
plane everybody's pissed and throwing
things in mad that they canceled and I'm
like okay this Airport's not safe and
and if it's not going out I need to go
get a taxi I go outside I get this this
taxi and he looked like he was legit I
says hey take me to the Marriott boom he
passes the Marriott I'm like what the
next exit next exit I'm like Marriott
there's no no hotel hotel right he takes
another exit and this is a shitty part
of town I'm talking there there's
there's prostitutes and I'm dressed like
the biggest Target on the planet and
there's there's big thugs that are
standing he goes oh tell him tell me to
get out I'm like no there's no way in
hell I'm getting out he had I'm sure he
had to deal with those guys fortunately
I had donated a bunch of money to the to
the police department and helped him
with some things and I got an honorary
Colonel badge right he's a freaking
badge badge right I'm digging through my
bag I pull it out and I'm like policia
Marriott
now my city Spanish right tell him to
take me to the Marriott and he's like
okay so so that was my first experience
in Colombia dressed like a target of
course that next morning and we get to
the Marriott there's guys with full
automatic weapons out in front as guards
I'm I mean this is a serious place in
front of the the elevator going up
there's guys with automatic weapons and
so so the next morning I get back to the
airport fly in and and I'm thinking the
whole time I'm thinking John was right
you know my business partner have you
thought through this I'm thinking yeah
that was that maybe I should have
thought through this that was that was
super dangerous already in uh and be in
this position and the reality is they
didn't have time to set up on that first
operation now the 60 plus after that I
was Paul Stone Paul black Paul you know
all of Paul Steele undercover profiles
everything set up they didn't have time
for that we had 24 hours from the time
that he was showing the traffickers this
is the guy that's going to come and fund
this I went down as Paul Hutchinson
that by itself is dangerous right super
dangerous and so you know they they
picked me up at the airport these two
Navy Seals big ass dudes you know
they're my show bodyguards and my real
bodyguards and a fully armored car I'm
like damn this is this is sketch and and
we pull into this restaurant and there's
this balcony that's overlooking the
beach and we're parked there on the
beach and these guys are you know show
they're going out looking around but the
traffickers are looking from the top
with the undercover CSI agents and
whatnot that are up there and so I get
out I walk in and these guys are they're
pissing themselves they're like yeah
this is the guy that's gonna fund our
missions and whatever else but I'm like
I'm I'm in a dangerous place if if if if
they the only thing that really kept it
going was the fact that they thought
that their whole world was going to be
made right by me you know there's
there's no reason to take me out there
because I'm gonna fund their project and
they're going to be making tens of
millions of dollars a year off these
Americans that were coming down so
that's the only thing they're really
kept me safe in that situation
negotiated with them sat there halfway
through the meeting one of them in the
movie this is depicted with me in the in
the Mercedes where where my driver gives
me a picture of this 11 year old girl in
real life I was already there I was
sitting across from the traffickers and
this one he was so excited I was willing
to take a look at the project he goes
Pablo have a gift for you I said really
what's your gift and he hands me his
phone and there's a picture of this
little 11 year old girl he said this is
Princess
she's still a virgin she's 11. he
started talking about these horrific
things I could do this little girl and
that galvanized my commitment to to in
fact the Navy sealed it was standing
right behind me he's like I need to go
take a look at the restaurant whatever
make sure everything was all safe later
on in our debriefing he's like you know
I almost unholstered my weapon right
there and shot him in the head because
that little girl looked like my little
girl at home and I realized that if I if
I broke my my undercover I we could lose
the rest of those kids I'm like yeah
yeah that's great that's what we want
and then he's like yeah we just took
delivery of some and I realized if we
can get these kids out
before they're ever rape the first time
that would be a miracle and I said Fuego
I said you have more virgins oh yeah I
got three or four more I said you have
to bring those to the party too he goes
oh no they're too expensive too
expensive I'm already paying 25 000 for
this party I'm paying 500 per child for
50 Children just for two hours in the
afternoon with him he goes Jefe you
already paid 25 000. you want to F the
other virgins it can cost you extra two
thousand maybe five thousand for that
little one it's gonna cost you maybe 10
000 more I was so pissed I mean I'm in a
I'm in a really expensive suit and I'm
like and I'm like you don't think I can
afford an extra ten thousand dollars
he's like oh no Hefe no I said I want
every one of those virgins on my party
they damn well better be virgins when
they get there they're not for you
they're for me and my guys you
understand he goes oh yeah if they
understand the stupid smile on his face
so two weeks later we fly back in the
guys meet with US Embassy the Colombian
federal agents and that's that's where
this thing happened
so you're not were you involved did you
need to be back there at all when yeah
stuff was going on yeah yeah so two
weeks later I flew back in because I'm
having the party and they they need to
see that I'm there with my with my guys
and they're gonna bring the kids and so
we rented this island there was this
private island out away and we we the we
told the traffickers meet on the on the
the bank area
um on the the on the mainland with all
the kids they showed up with 54 children
almost every one of them were under the
age of 16 years old many of them were
kidnapped from other countries and I'm
sitting there you know pretending like
this is my big party now my buddies from
my party are all former Special Forces
guys and stuff that are all hanging
around but I'm sitting there these guys
showed up with these kids we put the
kids in a in a safe place in this kind
of Cabana area in the house and we have
this table outside and we're sitting
there negotiating with these guys and we
have undercover cameras to be able to
catch everything they're saying because
we don't want the children to ever have
to stand trial and and testify we need
and that was a dark conversation super
dark because we have to get them to say
why how old the kids were what they were
willing to do where they got them all of
this stuff in that conversation so we
could and and it was really really dark
in fact we had a a situation that was
that was super dangerous we were
supposed to order tequila once we had
all the information we're like order
tequila and that was the sign line where
you know we had they had 40 federal
agents that were on this case four of
them were posing as our maids and our
waiters and our Cooks you know the rest
of them were there to storm the party
you know they weren't very good Cooks
but they're armed right and and we're
supposed to give this this signal to
them and there's they're supposed to
come out and and call and two three
minutes later they're supposed to storm
at all so as soon as we have all the
information we're like okay Kiki let's
order tequila let's get the party
started boom we ordered tequila two
minutes past 5 10 15. it was 45 minutes
now in the movie we depicted it like
they were waiting for the other kids in
reality the kids were already there but
45 minutes later before the agents
actually came we found out later that it
was it was uh somebody from the child
protective services the boss of all of
them that slept through her alarm and
missed the boat coming out and she's
like no we can't do this thing without
me there
worse the problem was we had just
started the party tequila it's time to
bring out cocaine and the kids and
everything else and we have to figure
out how to delay for 45 minutes
so what did you do
well this was
now I'm Not tooting my own horn but this
is where it was a damn good thing that I
had done a bunch of mergers and
Acquisitions and business stuff right
because they get up and one says oh I'm
gonna go get the kids I'm gonna go get
the cocaine I'm like and we can't
do that you know so I said guys guys
guys you know what
did you bring out the kids and the
cocaine I'm gonna get up for the
next two days I'm not gonna be able to
think I'm gonna have such a great time
but you've proven to me what you said
you could do our deal was this we're
gonna have a party you show up with the
inventory you have if I'm happy with
that inventory I'm gonna fund your
project so let's let's figure that out
right now somebody bring me a notebook
and a pan boom they bring me a notebook
pen and I start drawing out this
business plan Chris this is where it got
dark right because this business plan
penciled
and it was it was horrific I'm like okay
so with this business plan we drew out
what the what the resort was going to
look like I'm still delay delay delay
where's the freaking agents right and
then I'm like okay let's let's put
together a spreadsheet here let's let's
talk about the cost of goods what is it
going to what does it cost for you to
bring in a little Colombian girl oh 2500
when you get one you know okay what does
it cost for an American little blonde
girl what was that going to cost 25 000.
I'm writing these numbers down right and
then I don't know how dark you want me
to go but but okay I'm going there I'm
like okay so you're charging me two
thousand to five thousand dollars for
these virgins right are you just
me over or or is that really what you're
charging they're like yeah yeah that's
what really charge so I'm writing these
numbers down I say okay after you rent
them out the first time
then how much does the cost go down and
then the female trafficker the one that
in the movie was the one that was
running the the the modeling agency she
says oh no she said we can we can rent
them out more than once as a virgin
and I'm like I'm like well I got my
pants I'm like what what do you mean
she said about 200 for an operation to
sew back their hymen and I'm like what I
couldn't believe what I was hearing I
mean not only are they selling these
children like their cattle
they're talking about things like that
and I thought what has the world come to
where any person on the planet thinks
that that's okay
any person on the planet and so I'm like
okay that's getting heavy so I'd change
the subject I'm like okay I'm still
delaying I'm like okay you know I'll
fund your your modeling agency let's
talk about that tell me the details and
a lot of the stuff that went into the
movie was from that conversation the
details that we got of where they were
getting the kids and how they brought
them in finally I mean it was half an
hour into it and I still hadn't agents
hadn't come finally I said guys you know
what I like what you're where you're
going with this you've proven that you
can do it all anything I invest in yeah
I want control I'm taking 55 I'll give
you the money I said there's another 45
and I pointed at one of the guys his
name was Eduardo I said I said you you
get you've done most of the work I think
you should get 35 the other guys can
split the other ten and then they're
like I says you know what why don't you
guys figure it out I want it I want to
pencil this right here I want to put
document whatever it is and they argued
boom these traffickers against each
other for the next 15 minutes until the
agents came arrested everybody and threw
us all on the ground but that was that
was sketch and it was a damn good thing
that I knew what I was doing when it
came to writing out business plans what
what is it like when the
Armed Forces finally get there and
blasts through like is it just the the
highest adrenaline that you've ever felt
chaos chaos because they've got they've
got live rounds right and and they're
they're pointing them at all of us and
the bad guys have to think that we were
arrested and taken to the US to stand
trial right they can't think that we
were even involved and so so we had uh
Sean the Attorney General this was
before he actually became a g he was
standing right behind me he was Opera he
was we called him La Sombra the the
shadow right he was really my translator
because my Spanish sucks and uh and he
he in it as soon as they all came in he
he takes me to the ground to protect me
you know as my protector whatever is my
and and he's we're laying there on the
ground in the sand ants crawling over
the top of us they're throwing all the
traffickers down everybody's getting
handcuffed and we're laying there as
they're interrogating them and it's it's
going on and on now they take the
traffickers off the island
and and but the traffickers see us being
laid down sen and then the child
protective service people are in with
the children and then I we they were
able to get up and I went into the the
side part of the house where where some
of our bags were and I'm getting one of
the bags like one of my operators was
there and because it had a grass roof on
this this building you could hear what
was going on in the other rooms
and you could hear the kids in there
and they were laughing and they were
they were you know joking with the child
protective service were trying to calm
them down and that sound of freedom
versus The Crying that I heard half an
hour before that was the most beautiful
sound that I ever heard and I started
crying and and I turned to the operator
and I said well I spent my whole life
making rich people richer
I want to make a difference
I I I'm obviously what's what's happened
with
these young children is that they've
been psychologically manipulated in a
variety of ways to get them to
um collaborate or or at least not not
protest yeah how do you or the child
protective services people get past that
level of manipulation when trying to
convince the kids to now trust you was
not someone that's again this is just
the next set of traffickers that are
going to sell me to some some other
awful person well first of all the kids
in all the missions that I've done the
kids don't know the we were the good
guys you know and we have a whole
separate team this goes and helps them
with the rehabilitation and and and
working through that I will say that's
where the real rescue is pulling them
out of hell is the easy part
bone the hell out of them that's the
hard part you know and helping them heal
and uh I will say that you put these
kids in a healthy home
that has the love that they need we have
a we have a wonderful organization that
we partner with so my Foundation is the
child Liberation Foundation you can go
to liberatechildren.org and find us
there but we we partner with a number of
other ones and there's one I love it's
out of Guatemala called the hope of Life
foundation and they've helped over 30
000 victims recover and their model is
beautiful they have this property that's
way away from the city and they have
this Farm in this Ranch area and then
they they they have poor families a mom
and a dad and maybe one child or
whatever that can't afford living where
they were and then they have wealthy
donors that'll come down and say okay
I'm gonna build a house it's only going
to cost 10 grand for a beautiful two or
three bedroom house there and they bring
this family in and they say okay here's
the deal we're going to give you a house
and we're going to give you a job and
we're going to give you three more
children
right and so there's these children that
have been taken from these horrible
situations and instead of just putting
them into a foster home or what and you
know something that's going to be
perpetuating the problem they put them
into a healthy home with a healthy
family that can give them the love they
need and then of course you've got the
therapy and the psychology and
everything else as part of it the hard
ones Chris are the ones that that here
in the U.S this is the hardest ones the
ones that were abused by their own Cola
by their dad or were sold by their mom
when they were younger and then their
entire life they've had to hold this in
and they've built these layers and
layers and layers of protection around
themselves and then finally they get to
the point where they're talking about in
10 years of therapy they're still having
a hard time breaking through it in fact
the average age of somebody that talks
about child abuse that they went through
the average age is 52 years old that's
my age you know I have grandkids they've
spent their entire life
dealing with that kind of trauma so
helping them work through that that's a
whole different ball game you put these
children in a healthy home it's amazing
how fast they can bounce back
that's crazy so okay you do this first
one and that seems like a real baptism
of Fire
to be the first mission that you go on
why or how do you decide that you're
going to continue to do this I
understand the motivation right like I
I'm all in and this thing's terrible and
I can enact change and so on and so
forth but you supposed to be a
businessman you're supposed to have
responsibilities family kids you know
other to do and now you've got to
what like just Bruce Wayne Batman your
life in half and and go off and do this
stuff how does how do you fit it in how
does it all that integration work so
I'll tell you a quick story I uh
about a year or two into doing the
rescues a few years into it I I had
gotten a divorce I was with I was dating
a girl that I ended up marrying later
but I I was dating her and and she had
we're getting pretty serious and she had
a little nine-year-old and 11 year old
boy of her own and she said I I'd come
back from one of the pre-ops and a week
later I was going down for the actual
Sting the operation and she said you
know what Paul I've been thinking about
this a lot and I I if we're going to
make this work we you've got to change
that this is this is I just I have so
much anxiety every time you go I just
can't do it and and you know I I felt
compassion for where she was coming from
because yeah I'm sure that was super
difficult but her her two boys had a
little girl that was from the
neighborhood that was playing and I
think her name was Jessica and I I said
she was in the other room I said hey
Jessica come in here for a minute she
comes in I said how old are you she said
I'm 10 almost 11. I said what do you do
for fun she goes well I I ride my bike I
like to sing I like to dance I said what
do you want to be when you grow up
she said maybe be a dancer maybe be a
nurse beautiful dreams for 11 year old
child right I had her go play in the
other room and I turned to my girlfriend
and I said the children those
traffickers showed me yesterday
were her age
and if I don't go back down somebody
very likely is going to buy them and can
you imagine the lives that they live
they deserve to want to enjoy riding
their bikes they deserve to want to grow
up to be a dancer or a nurse
and just because those kids maybe their
parents don't have the resources I do or
the background doesn't mean they love
them any less or even if the kids
parents were involved which happens it
doesn't mean that that child is worth
any less than any of the other ones
so you had to make a lot of sacrifices
personally in order to be able to keep
this thing going okay so what were the
most
dangerous situations that you found
yourself in I mean it doesn't sound like
that first one was completely
undangerous you're being thrown on the
ground there's live ammunition there's a
lot of problems and complications but
was there something where you thought
this could really really go nuclear
pretty quickly oh yeah yeah so the first
year and a half I was going in is Paul
Stone right Paul stone is a wealthy
Playboy I've got pictures of
Lamborghinis for eyes whatever else and
and that was actually fairly safe
because once I showed up the undercover
guys were already with the guys they
said listen Paul Stone's coming with his
party no knives no guns no problem you
know and it's pretty controlled we've
got a lot of guys there after about a
year and a half I was asked to start
doing deep cover and this dangerous for
the wealthy guy to do Deep Cover so I
had to change my profile instead I'm
working for a rich guy right and so I'm
I'm now Paul Steele and Paul Steele is
working for a guy with money named Mateo
and he's so I then because I had I had
done enough of these things I then
started going in two in the morning
downtown Port-au-Prince Haiti connecting
with the worst part of humanity that are
selling it year old kids and and finding
where they're holding because our goal
is to get to where they're holding them
if it's not just taking down the
pedophiles not just taking down The
Pimps but we've got to get to their
suppliers that that are physically
controlling the kids because then I can
geotag the location of where they're
keeping them or they bring the children
out so that we can then do the sting and
rescuing from there so that's the goal
is to get to the boss's boss and I was
in I was in Latin America I met with
this guy super dangerous man he's six
foot three killed lots of people and and
and everybody cowered to him everybody
the everybody everybody all the drug
dealers stuff hey yeah yeah this guy is
the boss this guy's the boss well
connected with him told him listen he'll
pay you a couple hundred bucks each time
you you I can't my boss will kill me if
I taste the candy but I have to verify
you have the candy so I'll pay you if
you show me where they are well he
showed us some kids we knew that he was
legit the next morning he calls Pablo I
have to show you something I have to
meet after meet I said okay so we we we
meet he jumps in the car he's all right
we got to go somewhere got to go I said
we're gonna go see some more kids I'll
pay you some more money if you show me
your where you're we're keeping the
other ones he goes no he says you know
I'm the boss he says you know I'm the
king right I said what he goes I'm the
boss I said oh yeah it's very obvious
you're the boss of this whole city he
goes every boss has a boss and I'm going
to take you to see my boss he's in
charge of and and this guy was Man In
Charge right I get out of the car and
this guy's talking back and forth super
dangerous conversation he says he says
uh he said give me your business card I
pull out my business card my undercover
one Paul Steele he looks at it he says
tell me your phone number
now if I didn't have no we saw at least
three and this one met with him later
there was eight of these these guys that
were watching us that were had guns
behind that that building everything
else and he says he says he says tell me
your phone number and I had it memorized
just like that he says tell me your
address and then he says show me your
phone and I pulled out my phone he says
show it to me so I show my phone to him
and he dials the phone number that's on
my undercover to make sure it's ringing
to my phone
and it rang
and he smiles he says I like you
he ended up bringing 24 children he was
he was the king he was the boss of that
whole area the federal police said that
they'd been trying to get in touch with
him for three years and I got his phone
number in 24 hours so but that was super
dangerous if I didn't have that number
memorized if I didn't have all of the
things set up properly where my
undercover phone was ringing to that we
would have been done right there
what would the places you went to you
mentioned an area of Haiti that but I
imagine it's been a like a world tour of
the most destitute awful locations for
this sort of stuff what are some what
are some of the others that stunned up
more than half the children that were
rescued in Thailand were sold by their
own families
super just poverty there and and feeling
like you know what if you're going to be
better off in a brothel and we can now
have enough money to be able to pay for
the food for our kids that was super sad
um there were a lot of children a lot of
children in the island of Haiti is also
shared with the Dominican Republic and
the Dr
um there was we did a lot of operations
that were there in the Dominican
Republic and there was a lot of very
very young kids very very sad situation
there all over Latin America
um some of the best law enforcement I've
ever worked with as the the guys in the
federal police in Mexico we followed a
bunch of leads there in Mexico from
different areas and trafficking to other
Beach areas for the Americans
um we've we've been in in Nicaragua and
uh been in in Costa Rica
um we've been on a lot of areas of Latin
America down in Peru how uh Ecuador how
did you avoid
getting into it just seems like you know
you do the 70 times you do anything 70
times things are going to go wrong you
know the first one that you ever did
it's 45 minutes waiting given
the people that are doing this aren't
exactly going to be uh the most balanced
in the world they're not they're not
they haven't got to the position that
they're in because they're reasonable
um it just seems surprising to me that
you managed to get through so many
operations without like Beyond someone
getting punched in the face like we had
we had one of our operators got stabbed
27 times
um we had another he lived through it he
was in Dominican Republic
um he was just fighting out they count
every single little poke is a stab you
know when they're doing the taking you
in the hospital afterwards but we had
another one in um who we had we had got
to pretty high level political leaders
in this country that were involved I'm
not going to say the country but pretty
high level political leaders that were
involved and had taken down some corrupt
judges and whatnot and and our top
operator there that was working in the
federal police
um
ended up dying of a heart attack the
same week that three other political uh
enemies were died of a heart attack and
so you know I count that as a as a
tragedy of of one of our one of our
operators as well how much of an
emotional toll did all of this take on
you
That's Heavy
it's heavy when you know when you're
when you're in that
level of darkness is super heavy and um
and and I'll I'll just I'll just tell
you what happened and about seven years
ago I had been doing operations for
three and a half years
about six six and a half years ago and
one of my operators
came to me and he said Paul do you trust
me I said yeah I trust you 100 I mean
we're doing this now I was living in
this
I was still Paul Stone you know I wasn't
Paul I wasn't Paul Hutchins I was
Paul Hutchinson right I had this
huge lifestyle I had the best stories on
the planet you know I could it was just
that that energy right and and it was
cool I was choosing this big ego to help
go rescue kids but from a heart
standpoint I had dysfunctional
relationships I was I was on my my
halfway through my second marriage on
the way out I mean it was just super
just dysfunctional as a whole and and
and it was it was that toll was taking
place on some of my operators as well
and one of them came in and he said Paul
he said I know that you've been
searching for something that can help a
lot of these trauma victims especially
the adult ones who have been holding it
in for a long time he said we found
something and I think it's going to help
you as well I'm like I don't need help
I'm Paul F and Hutchinson no it will and
I I was invited into my first
guided meditation
plant medicine Journey experience and it
changed everything for me everything it
transformed my life it helped me I had
all of these just just negative emotion
that was just bound up inside me and I
was able to let it go let go of stuff
for my own childhood let go of stuff
that were it was created from my own
arrogance and my own ego and and let go
of a lot of that negative energy of
being in the pit of Hell
did that make you less effective at your
job afterward
the more I did the more I couldn't do it
yeah yeah you know I can't I I just yeah
I've now
um
you know I did I did some rescue
missions last year but that was almost a
three-year hyenas from the time that I
had my last ones before that and I was
in Ecuador last year and I had I had
changed so much from the man that I was
six years ago that being in that
darkness and seeing that I thought this
is a reason why I decided to go public I
thought there's got to be a better way
there's there's something that I can do
to use my resources my voice my
experiences to to end child trafficking
that doesn't take me into that I can I
can for the rest of my life I can share
these stories of being in the pit of
Hell but I don't have to go back there
and I can fix it from this angle instead
yeah if if the
like
post-mortem on going and doing an
operation is that you need a course of
ibogaine in Ayahuasca to be able to get
through it then I don't know I feel like
yeah there's it's a high personal price
to pay
um one of the things that's obviously
very interesting about the sound of
freedom is how controversial its release
has been it's called an awful lot of
press why do you think it is that it was
so controversial for what is a
relatively non-political movie yeah
um
we had pushback from the beginning Chris
we had we we went in right from the
beginning we went into guys like
Paramount and Sony and Lionsgate and had
the story of that rescue and they they
were interested but they that they it
came with conditions where they wanted
full control they could have they could
have had one of my operators touching a
child in the middle of the operation and
just make it you know it's stuff like
that that no that's not what it's about
you know we wanted to have it from the
heart so we we we knew that it had to be
self-funded and so I put the first money
in to me to to do all the scripting and
then even after that from uh creation of
the the movie itself we knew that those
guys wouldn't do the work that that we
needed have done so we we painstakingly
found the very best guys to do it and
then the movie was finished five years
ago five years ago and we were ready for
distribution and we ended up getting
pushed back everywhere at the the
traditional distribution models the only
way we were able to bring it to the
world is to go around the existing
system right the existing system of
control that is put in place by big
media big Tech and big Hollywood to
control what kind of stuff is being put
into your mind in your kids mind we we
had to go around that and so going
through Angel Studios was was something
where we could go from the people for
the people right where it was supported
with this Grassroots movement this pay
it forward type of a thing is is is what
really worked and so I will say this
um there have been
there have been
things where some of the actors have
have have been very very political in
the last few years you know Jim Caviezel
is an amazing amazing actor
but in terms of of of taking a broad
swath through the population say this is
something we can all get behind it
doesn't work if you're if you're talking
about adrenochrome and and q1 and things
and whatever else right and so so my
answer to that is this you know I I uh I
see myself as a conservative you know
and I I've voted that way most of my
life
but this is not a political issue this
isn't a rich versus poor this isn't a
black versus white this isn't it right
versus left this is about the children
and until we can come together on that
then we're going to continue to have
these problems and so it shouldn't be
political but unfortunately some people
see it as that is it a red flag given
Hollywood's history with people like
Jeffrey Epstein and stuff like that
obviously the conspiracy theories almost
write themselves with a film like this
about a topic like this not being green
lit and yet you know for every
conspiracy theory there's probably a
perfectly legitimate uh reason for why
this film wouldn't be able to be worked
for whatever reason
have you got a grander conspiracy in
your head yeah so so pre-launch I could
probably get behind the the notion that
hey uh I don't think this is what the
public really wants and so this is so
pre-launch I could understand that some
of them were turning us down because
maybe it wasn't something so I could
maybe look at that but now post lunch
with the massive success and that the
fact that the masses are wanting to go
to it and it's it's gaining so much
momentum with these guys now
blatantly coming out against it you have
to ask yourself why
okay and I'll tell you this it's not
just the children in Colombia that are
in slavery it's you and I it's the
average adult that allows themselves to
be controlled by this Mass psychosis
that that that a very few people have
decided this is the agenda this is
what's going to be fed to you this is
what's going to be fed to your kids and
this is the road that you're going to
slowly be led down until we get to this
point
and and as soon as we take a step back
and say no we're not interested in that
we're not interested in in movies that
are that are promoting things that are
not in line with with my core values yet
we've spent so many years quietly
stepping back saying oh it's not that
bad it's not that bad and every time we
say it's not that bad it gets a little
bit worse and so now this is coming out
blatantly in their face no this is
something that we can all get behind and
they're like oh no we can't we can't
have that message out what what do you
think is the road that uh people are
trying to be walked down here obviously
you've spent not only before you started
doing this because of your wealth level
that'll have given you access to a lot
of uh high-level individuals actually
this is this is let's ask this first
outside of your time working with uh
working with the child trafficking stuff
what are the sorts of people that you've
met at the wealth level that you're at
and above
have you met any people who you've been
scared of having the sort of resources
that they do you know people that that
achieve very very extreme wealth have
done it for a particular reason
one of the things that is often a
limiting factor for people with
nefarious ideologies or views about the
world or plans that they want to enact
is that they don't have the resources to
be able to make it happen and as you get
toward the multi multi multi-billion
dollar net worth individual you end up
with somebody who might very well have
the psychopathology
and
essentially unlimited ability to make
things happen have you met people in
business meetings or at these
conferences or at dinners that are
terrifying to sit across from what's
that like absolutely yeah I'll tell you
a story 2012.
I had just surpassed two billion dollars
in asset Center management I was the
number one performing real estate
investment Fund in the U.S and started
getting invited to different conferences
with the ultra Elite and I got invited
to a very special one the the the top of
the top of the top we're talking
multi-multi-generational billion dollar
families that are really pulling the
strings and
um now I know a lot of wealthy families
that are really good people but we're in
this room and before and I was there
supposing to I was going to speak about
some of our investment strategies
because we were doing really well I mean
High double digit returns and so so uh
but I was sitting there and this guy
came up before I did and he he had a he
had a spreadsheet and he posted up on
the wall and it was population he says
that this you know where this population
here we're going to hit 8 billion people
by 2024 or 9 billion here et cetera et
cetera and then he said he said the the
um the problem is he said the baby
boomer age we've known about it whole
life that starting in 2016 that the
percentage of people that are over 65
years old and aging out of the workforce
he says it will become completely
unsustainable
and and there's no way that we can
sustain financially the people moving
out of the workforce the population he
said and and it was a pitch an absolute
pitch for population control right there
in front of these guys the and I was saw
it with my own eyes right there and he
he talked about how with the new medical
advancements how literally if you have
enough money 20 years from now
and you're relatively good health you
can live to 200 years old right with the
medical advancements taking off like
they are Etc and then he says something
about how the the the the ideal
population for this Earth is about 500
million seven billion people less than
we had at the time right and so so I'm
I'm sitting there thinking is everybody
going to start throwing up here no he
got a standing ovation right that scared
the out of me realizing that that
there are people in that Ultra Elite
mindset that truly think they see us
just like that female trafficker was
seeing those kids that could be sold a
second time you know as absolute
non-human and I thought how can you feel
that way about your fellow man but
that's exactly what I saw firsthand yeah
I have a friend Daniel who set up
somebody not too dissimilar and this
person was uh overtly talking about
being an apex predator he said when
you're an apex predator you don't care
about the prey and he was being sort of
very uh callous about the externalities
of whatever his business practices were
or whatever his plans were for what he
was doing professionally or personally
or whatever it might be and um yeah it's
it's interesting to consider what
happens to the human psyche when you
you have such a long ladder that were
not evolved to have right you know we're
in small groups within a tribe of 150
small groups of you know between 30 and
40 little little pockets and then to be
able to go okay I can no longer be
first out of 40 I can be like a
hundredth out of 7.8 billion people it's
I I it's almost like a vertigo but
status vertigo and I wonder what it does
to the psyche of someone that wasn't
built to uh well in a well-balanced
manner be able to deal with that yeah
well it's it's one of the reasons why I
was recruited to do the undercover work
is unfortunately you take you take guys
who have had
you know a shitty childhood and they got
low self-esteem and a huge ego and a big
checkbook and they pretty much conquered
everything and they've gotten to the
point where they are effing everybody
and that doesn't really do it for them
anymore and so it's this this apex
predator type of a mindset and it grows
and grows into this point where they
they think it said it's okay if I rape a
12 year old I was right to 12 years old
what does that mean you know and that's
that's that that that energy that
unfortunately is the type of guys that
are going down paying 50 or 100 000 for
one of these sex parties with kids in
Colombia that's why I was chosen that's
why it wasn't so strange for traffickers
in multiple countries for The Operators
to come in and say hey there's this this
profile of this Paul Stone and it's got
all this stuff and he's coming down yeah
of course yeah we met with guys just
like that that's who's that's who our
clients are so now I'm not saying that
it's just the rich guys who are the
clients but but I am saying that that
arrogant once
tied together with unresolved trauma
tied together with unlimited resources
you know they say that that power
corrupts and absolute power corrupts
absolutely and unfortunately you got a
lot of people that think that they have
that absolute power
um
what
what is the current state of the world
of child sex trafficking I mean you know
it seems like your guys have tried to
work pretty hard at this we've got this
film that's come out now
in terms of operations have you even
made a dent or is this like trying to
put a sand castle up against a tide no
it's the opposite Chris so here's the
thing
10 years ago when I was sitting on that
chair and they presented these little
virgins and they were scared to death
and I made that commitment at the time
there was approximately 8 million
children that were being sold for sex in
the movie we talked about over 2 million
children a year being sucked in those
are new ones that are coming in but the
the numbers were approximately 10 8
million children they're being sold the
end of last year I finished up some
rescue stuff in in South America and I I
looked at the numbers
and statistically they said there's
approximately 10 million today so if my
goal was to eradicate child trafficking
I wasn't doing a very good job right
pulling 20 children out of out of hell
yes it made a massive difference to them
but then we spend the next five to
twenty years dealing with their trauma
and helping them and because not enough
was being done to fix the demand side it
created a vacuum and another 20 children
were being sucked into the deepest
recesses of hell so I took a step back
and I'm like okay well undercover
rescue's not fixing this problem I've
got to figure out how to fix the demand
what does that look like and for a while
I thought well maybe I need to go out
against pornography because all of these
guys start out with a hardcore addiction
that that became harder and harder
pretty soon they needed something
younger and younger but almost everybody
listening to me has seen pornography
just because you've seen pornography
doesn't mean you become a pedophile but
but when you take a woman from a divine
feminine to an object you do start going
down a dark Road tied in with that ego
in that arrogance and that
commoditization Etc however even that is
a symptom of a deeper problem right it's
it's the fact that that we've we've
allowed our our our media and Hollywood
and whatnot to start feeding us and
desensitizing us I mean are you kidding
me they're that their Netflix allowed
cuties to be their TV series yet they
didn't want to take sound to Freedom
okay really so you have to ask yourself
what kind of things are being promoted
and why have we let ourselves go there
that together with with unresolved child
trauma two out of three people who have
dealt with massive childhood sexual
trauma two out of three become really
good men and women they've dealt with
their they they use that as a
motivation to to protect innocence at
all costs however one out of three
end up becoming contact offenders and so
people ask me a lot they say Paul how
can you go face to face with somebody
selling an eight-year-old and not have
them
see the anger and hatred in your in your
in your eyes and my answer surprises
them
I said I part of me really feels bad for
him how can you feel bad for him they're
selling you an eight-year-old no I will
do everything in my power to ensure they
never hurt another child again but what
I wish more than anything is that I had
a time machine and I could go back five
years or ten years to the point before
they ever ever hurt a child and figure
out what the hell was going on in their
life they were likely raped as a child
themselves they had a thousand bad
things happen in a thousand bad
decisions that got them to the point
where they thought that that was okay
and now we don't have time machines but
what we do have is hundreds of millions
of people on this planet who who are
dealing with a level of crap in their
life that if we don't help them work
through it
will likely pass that trauma on to
others so if we can come from a place of
compassion and love those kids those
teenagers that dealt with that and give
them the health that they need
I think will save millions of children
what's the next steps what are you
planning on doing to try and impact this
further what can people they're
listening doing if they feel compelled
to contribute
two things I opened up a website
literally last week called liberating
Humanity liberating Dash humanity and
you can follow me on all my social media
you can just type in liberating I'm the
first one that comes up it's liberating
Humanity because that's what it's about
it's not just liberating the 10 year old
from the clutches of trafficker it's
liberating Humanity which will in turn
save those 10 year olds before they're
ever raped in the first place that's my
primary goal you can go to
liberatechildren.org and and get
involved from the actual child rescue
stuff we're still funding operations of
of guys that are going in and taking out
pedophiles Etc and are cleaning things
up but my goal personally now that I've
decided that that my voice is more
powerful than than my body being
undercover and so being on podcasts like
this one with your amazing audience I
mean it's you being able to take your
your lifetime of work of of accumulating
this following and and being willing to
bring me on and have me share my voice
my passion my heart I believe I believe
that is going to help save children I
really do I think that there are people
who are listening right now that are
like you know what yeah I'm dealing with
some stuff whatever go get the help that
you need come on to liberating
liberating humanity and and download
some stuff and get some help so that you
can work through your trauma because
we love you we know that that's super
difficult to be holding on to that so
let's release it and and stop the
generational trauma stop the demand site
so that we can eradicate child
trafficking
Paul I love your energy I think that
you've made an awful lot of sacrifices
in order to be able to get this across
the line I really really hope that
everything you do in future goes Super
well to uh everything that we've spoken
about everyone should go and check that
out I I really do think that you know
it's a problem that's been hiding in
plain sight you need a landmark event
like the one that you've been a part of
to to bring public attention to
something that really needs it
thank you Chris honored honored to be on
your show if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe